what it is
I'm Cyrus filling in for Greg who's off
doing something
I don't even want to think about
he did call though he was breaking up in
the phone and all I got out of it was
gasoline and kill Mead's house
so kill Mead watch your six
no way this Greg Watcher three
[Laughter]
all night gut failed anyway Christmas is
coming gone and boy have we been given
some doozies of gifts this year
worse than fruitcakes or when I got Dana
and Greg that gift card for the big and
tall shop they had it coming they're
always getting me small stuff
now when I was a kid and I got a gift I
didn't like well you just accepted it
and when it was worse than when your mom
told you to you know like you just wore
it when she said so
nothing like socks and underwear wrapped
like an awesome toy to make you say your
first cuss words under your breath
I don't know why they didn't wrap them
nobody else in the house wears a size
called duplex pair of socks but me
and then Mom would say
I know you didn't ask for it but Santa
knew you needed it
thanks a lot Santa
the following year when I put him in
that headlock
but I was the bad kid what did I know I
was five
and it's weird so he spies on me all
year that he breaks into my house and
it's okay because he brought socks
I feel right well this year as a country
we were given a lot of odd gifts
and definitely more than just some fancy
ass wrap socks
from our wonderful Administration
we got this guy
Secretary of Homeland Security Alejandro
mallorcas
yeah he was wrapped in a bow first
openly lying on men and women on the
border
and then if that wasn't a giant bag of
coal he also claimed the abide
administration had effectively managed
the Border crisis
but if that was true then it wouldn't be
a crisis
let that marinate for a second
meanwhile he was all
afflecting blame like a goalie in the
Stanley Cup finals but on who oh yeah
the wonderful men and women of our
border patrol agents and of course the
racist ass horses
but hey they probably came from the polo
circuit always bragging about being
related to Seabiscuit
[Laughter]
and if that wasn't bad enough these
horse supremacists all their saddlebags
said coach
[Laughter]
and they think non-thoroughbreds should
be sent to the glue factory
tough crowd
yeah they got more heat than Rudolph the
Red-Nosed Reindeer did at the Santa
Christmas party when they found an open
bottle of Jack Daniels next to him and
him claiming the Red Nose isn't from
booze
so at least my orcas could have
done while he was throwing the agents
under the bus was just while they're
down there have them check to see if
there's any fentanyl tape to the
undercarriage
and just when you think there can't be a
worse gift
than that oh I hate Mallorca I don't
mind telling you
then you had good old Auntie Kamala
showing up digging in her bag of laughs
like there were fries in the bottom of
the bag
you know in the fries you want to you're
going to get that yeah
she laughs for no reason like she was
watching Joe DeVito and Joe maki's
stand-up special hey I did not approve
that
I did not approve that
I'll talk to y'all during the commercial
break
Gene you got a spot coming up
but boy does she sure have The Gift of
Gab
you need to get to go I need to be able
to get where you need to go to do the
work and get home when we talk about the
children of the community
they are a children of the community the
significance of the passage of time so
when you think about it there is great
significance to the passage of time who
doesn't love a yellow school bus it's
part of our our experience growing up
it's part of you know a Nostalgia and a
memory the school bus takes us there
[Laughter]
if that made any sense to you
lay off the eggnog someone has spiked it
with Pine-Sol
and don't worry about all the gifts you
don't really like this year we've got
good old-fashioned crime waves to take
care of that so your new gifts were
likely to get stolen at any point
and that's more of a merry middle finger
than a happy ho ho ho to the American
people speaking of hoe
we did get a gift from WWE legend
Hacksaw Jim Duggan thought I was going
to say something else
he showed us tough guys are real as he
stopped a home invasion with two things
that I love most his right to bear arms
and his wife's right to call the police
his home Invaders got the best gift of
all not getting his ass beat with a two
by four so we don't always get what we
want but sometimes you get gifts you
know for that spoiled brat
like the two I have on my show I can get
you out for that I'm talking about
Progressive liberals all they wanted for
Christmas was free speech on their
social media so in comes Old Saint musk
buying Twitter
but it's not the Free Speech we wanted
we wanted a free speech Just for us not
everyone else thanks Elon you're the
worst Saint musk ever
I worked hard on that voice thank you
that was my liberal voice
you just
squeeze your growing as hard as you can
and don't breathe and you can sound just
like them
the only thing worse than that is except
when former NWA world heavyweight
champion Trevor Murdock forgets the
shower look at that pitcher
put on a tie man or someone get him some
frankincense
love you Trevor thanks for the belt and
sometimes you get a gift that on the
picture of the Box looks good but when
you open it up the instructions are in
Chinese and the batteries aren't
included and even when you get the
batteries in it it still doesn't work
right and it makes Crazy sounds and
turns on and off for no reason and
wanders around
foreign
[Applause]
[Laughter]
when it comes to Christmas gifts there's
always one guy who gives you the gift
that's not for someone else but it's
really just for himself yeah you all
know who I'm talking about thanks Greg
foreign
so sick of this story in him
and what better Christmas gift than a
teacher who wants to eat drink and be
merry
[Applause]
let's welcome tonight's guests
her oats said Do no harm but she can't
help killing with kindness Fox News
contributor Dr Nicole Sapphire
the only thing missing from her Sports
resume is a beer commercial host of
sideline sanity's podcast Michelle
Tafoya
foreign
lines are often the result of him
getting punched Ryder and comedian Joe
DeVito
his laughs are as low as his
testosterone writer and comedian Joe
Mackey
okay I feel like we're even now fair
enough I've got your cheek plug
sorry about the testosterone thing
it's it's a doctor right over there
I'll start with the legend Mr foyer
should Republicans impeach Mallorca
okay so yes because you know and I don't
love this idea of this stack of
Investigations that is probably going to
happen but this guy needs to go he needs
to go he has not done his job well he is
he has as you mentioned throwing people
under the bus he's barely been to the
Border no one from this Administration
has so if there is one guy that needs to
be impeached I think this is the guy I
really do I think it's just I think this
has been the worst part hard to pick but
of Biden's presidency has been the
crisis at the border and if you're going
to point to one person I think you got a
point to my orcas it's not not so much
the fact that he just knowingly told a
lie they knew that the riding the horses
they weren't whipping anybody but that
pitcher pushed their their agenda so far
that they were worth when sacrificing
our men and women who protect our
borders and that to me I don't see how
that's not impeachable offense you just
you threw him under the bus you lied
about it and you never came clean about
it and now nobody trust you and you
claim to be doing a good job you know
look we knew when Biden at that debate
said everyone should surge the Border we
are a nation that welcomes Asylum
Seekers and refugees search The Border
well he did it they just weren't
prepared Tyrus and they've done a
horrific job handling it all right
Mackie what's your top story on my top
story of uh of this year is uh finally
after 70 years scientists have gotten
net energy from a fusion reaction and uh
this is not to Pat themselves on the
back because if you spend 70 years on
one project
that's easy like you could start your
career and retire
and nothing's done
I think we need to start firing
scientists because what have they done
with us lately like well they they've
delayed Aging in mice
and they they got us a covid vaccine
but they
made covid
hey look yeah and the vaccine sucks
foreign
the Elon Musk buying Twitter story also
includes all the Twitter files and
stories and all the dirty laundry that
that happened this year do you think
that's the biggest story of 2022 you
know I think it's going to be a big
story of 2023 I think the biggest story
of 2022 is the fact that you've had
President Biden and Tony fauci
continuing to perpetuous perpetuate the
state of panic that has kept us all in
for the last year when the coveted
emergency has been over 2023 it's going
to be a big deal listen you have Dr
fauci Who spent three decades in his
role as the Director at the NIH kind of
like our top ID doc of the country
failed miserably throughout the coveted
pandemic I'm like he had one job like
this was his moment he was ready to
knock it out of the park and he got it
wrong every step of the way all he had
to do was say hey you know what there's
a lot of things that I don't know at the
beginning of it but he didn't he's like
hey here's my opinion and that's a fact
and his facts actually turned out to be
wrong but the big story is going to be
the fact that anyone who didn't agree
with his facts were censored and that's
what's going to come out of 2023. what
about you know all the doctors that were
attacked for just actually following
this at yourself Dr Drew just to name a
few
where would you think there'll ever be
an apology or something you know what
I'm saying I know that's crazy right oh
I'm sorry we ruined your career first
merged your name
you know what I had there was a couple
of hit pieces about me earlier on during
the pandemic and I have noticed
throughout the course of the pandemic
they have gone off of the internet
because they have taken away those
articles did they issue an apology
absolutely not but at least they came
off the internet because they were wrong
and I'm sorry it wasn't in the beginning
I wasn't saying hey I'm right but I was
questioning what was happening and
that's what you should do as a scientist
yeah we take a long time sometimes I get
it we really do we draw things out but
at the end of the day to say I don't
know and maybe I got this wrong and I'm
evolving with more data that's how we
should have handled it and unfortunately
you know that didn't happen speaking of
evolving Joe
um what would you put your button on as
a story of the Year well I'd say this
year was the year of the woman
yeah whether it was uh Brittany Greiner
trying to smuggle weed into Russia or uh
Caleb and Mew getting her boobs stuck in
a band saw
[Laughter]
I learned that women can be just as
stupid as men
[Applause]
anyone can be a woman now
I think back to my gym teacher told me I
threw like a girl I didn't realize he
was empowering me
yes because now you can compete in
women's sports all right there we go
just like Leah Thomas you
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else